wm vorbereitungen für einen spitzenkoch
die kann auch so aus in wenigen wochen
geht es für wahl-münchner holger
stromberg mit der nationalmannschaft
nach brasilien
dabei ist fußball eigentlich ganz und
gar nicht sein metier ich bin großer
fußballfan klar ich bin ein ganz ganz
schlechter fußballspieler aber ich bin
eben in einer anderen branche
großgeworden mainfeld ist die küche das
kann ich da würde ich auch mal sagen da
spiele ich nationalmannschaft und da bin
ich richtig gut
holger stromberg erstellt für die
spieler einen strengen ernährungsplan
heute kommen fast nur noch
vollkornprodukte auf den tisch ganz
wichtig auch viel gemüse
doch damit salat bei allen spielern gut
ankommt muss sich der koch ins zeug
legen er verfeinert ihn beispielsweise
mit einer süß scharfen marinade das ist
alles ganz knackig ganz bunt und das
wird sehr sehr gerne genommen und so
kriege ich eben auch spannung ins gemüse
essen
die 60 besten turnier rezepte hat holger
stromberg jetzt in einem kochbuch
veröffentlicht denn geht es nach ihm
sollte sich jeder an der ernährung der
fußballer ein beispiel nehmen
heute sind dazu da sie zu essen und
nicht sie als dekoration auf die
fensterbank zu stellen dann kauft man
sich nämlich lieber ein kaktus der held
lange braucht wenig pflege aber kräuter
bester bund kaufen und viel verarbeiten
in wenigen handgriffen entsteht ein
vollwertiger salat
übrigens das lieblingsessen von
mittelfeldspieler mesut özil
kurz vor dem spiel wird das grünzeug
aber ersetzt durch einen bewährten
klassiker auch schon als aktiver spieler
nationalmannschaft gegessen das in
nudeln mit tomatensoße bolognese soße
und dann gibt es parmesan dazu einige
nimmst nur mit olivenöl 23 spieler 23
lieblingsgerichte und holger stromberg
kennt sie alle
meeresfrüchte salat für torwart manuel
neuer
verteidiger per mertesacker liebt
tomatensuppe und stürmer lukas podolski
blumenkohl scheinbar sie die fußballer
mittlerweile zu gummis geworden
deswegen macht es so wahnsinnig viel
spaß für die mannschaft zu kochen weil
sie sehr sehr feine zogen bekommen haben
und das ist wichtig das geht mir gar
nicht darum irgendwelche feinschmecker
aus ihnen zu machen sondern essen nach
güte zu bewerten nach einfach nach
energie reichtum und nach nach korrekten
natürlichen geschmack deshalb war auch
schon in brasilien um in allen deutschen
spielorten die besten lebensmittel zu
finden denn mitnehmen darf er nichts zur
wehr
seitdem agiere ich wie ein
trüffelschwein und das geht ja heute
gott sei dank durch internet und telefon
und was man alles hat und versuche eben
die besten lebensmittel für uns zu
ergattern
das ist auch meine kleine wm das ist ja
mein sport zu sagen ich will das beste
für die mannschaft und das hat jetzt
nichts mit puma oder langusten zu tun
sondern einfach einfache dinge die in
bester qualität und das ist in brasilien
gar nicht so einfach drei große turniere
hat holger stromberg bereits begleitet
wie hier 2012 die europameisterschaft in
polen und der ukraine
dabei versorgt er die nationalmannschaft
vom frühstückstisch bis in die kabine
20 stunden tage sind für holger
stromberg während einer meisterschaft
keine seltenheit
seit sieben jahren gehört der koch zum
offiziellen betreuerstab nebenbei leitet
er zwei restaurants in münchen und im
ruhrgebiet
und der einstige sternekoch besitzt
sogar eine imbisskette denn auch fast
food muss ab und zu mal sein
sowas gibts natürlich jetzt nicht vorm
spiel sei jeder meint so wir sind auf
einer urlaubsreise sondern das ist dann
schon belohnung und das wird dann auch
vom trainer genauso gestützt und gesehen
und teilweise daneben auch von ihm so
angeordnet dann wenn gut spiele gut
gelaufen ist dann sagt er sogar morgens
köln
ja und dann wird der grill aufgebaut und
dann gibt es geld und haben sich daher
dann auch verdient letzte kräfte sammeln
bevor in zwei wochen die arbeit beginnt
die mannschaft fährt ins trainingslager
nach südtirol mit seinem essen will er
die fußballer bereits dort auf
hochtouren bringen damit sein wunsch für
das team in erfüllung geht weltmeister